why does sweating cool you down
that is an excellent question lebron and
to answer it let's zoom in on a little
droplet of sweat and sweat is mostly
water so when we zoom in we've really
zoomed in even more than i've drawn over
here when we really zoom in we'll start
seeing mainly these water molecules and
the water molecules just to be a little
bit more accurate i've drawn the oxygen
in blue and then the hydrogens that are
that are bonded with that oxygen i've
done it in white we all know that water
is sometimes referred to as h2 that's
for the two hydrogens
h2o so each of these are a molecule of
h2o or a molecule of water what i've
drawn down here and this is an
oversimplification of the molecules of
your skin but just for that for
simplification these are the molecules
of your skin really the parts of the
skin cell these aren't even the skin
cells themselves these are the molecules
that make up the skin cells and right
over here these are molecules of sweat
or it's really just molecules of water
so the question of why does sweat cool
you down could really be restated as why
does having water on the surface of your
skin actually cool you down and to
answer that or to think about that
question we have to think about what it
means to have temperature or what
temperature even really means
temperature what we perceive as
temperature is really just the motion of
the molecules of something so a higher
temperature means that they're moving
around more so high temperature they're
moving around more low temperature
they're moving around less and they can
move around in different ways they can
have what you could call translational
motion which is they're actually moving
around they could be vibrating they
could be rotating in some way and in
general on average the more the more of
this motional energy often referred to
as kinetic energy
that these molecules have on average the
higher the perceived temperature would
be
now how does having this water here cool
down the skin and well first of all why
is this skin warming up because the
muscles are doing all of this work
they're releasing heat that heat is
is is being transferred to the skin but
then how does having this water here
help
well this skin has a certain temperature
a certain kinetic energy or emotional
energy but when we say that it doesn't
mean that all the all of these molecules
have the exact same motion the
temperature is the average motion some
of these some of these are bumping
around at a faster space speed or
vibrating at a faster speed or rotating
at a faster speed some are doing it at a
slower speed but as these bump around
they're going to bump into these water
molecules and start to get them moving
around they will probably be moving
around a little bit to begin with but
then the warmer this is the more energy
here they'll bump into these molecules
so let's say that guy bumps into that
then he'll bump over there and so that
energy
this bumping energy or this kinetic
energy will some of it will be
transferred or you could even say some
of that temperature some of that heat
will be transferred to these water
molecules to these water molecules but
the important thing to remember is not
all this is a really kind of crazy thing
they're all bumping into each other and
rotating in all sorts of crazy ways they
will have an average kinetic energy
which we perceive as temperature but all
have this one might be going really
really really fast well in that
direction while this one might be going
really really really really slow this
one might be going really really really
fast in that direction this one might be
going really slow in this direction so
the thing to think about is
given that you have all of this
variation in the in the in the energy of
each of these particles which of these
are most likely to escape to actually
evaporate and to think about evaporation
you just have to think about that most
water molecules or the water molecules
that are in that droplet they do have an
attraction to each other we call those
hydrogen bonds so they do they do have
they do have an attraction to each other
and that's why a droplet kind of sticks
together but if one of these molecules
is moving fast enough and if it's moving
in the right direction it has a higher
probability of being able to escape
being able to actually escape that
droplet and this process of these
molecules escaping that's what we refer
to as evaporation
evaporation if a molecule has enough
energy it'll escape this escape the
bonds with the other water molecules and
just evaporate and just evaporate into
and just evaporate into the air but we
still haven't fully answered our
question so let's say that this one has
is one that has evaporated it has fully
escaped
why would that actually cool down this
entire system why would it cool down the
droplet and essentially get have it
give it more capability to accept more
energy from the skin
well we just said the ones that have the
highest energy are the ones that are
most likely to escape the ones that have
the highest kinetic energy so if you
have a bunch of stuff some are fast some
are slow vibrating a lot vibrating less
but the ones that have a high kinetic
energy the ones most likely to escape
what happens when they escape well then
the average kinetic energy will go down
or you could say the temperature the
temperature
the temperature which is really just the
average amount of
motion or kinetic energy that's in this
in this droplet if the really fast ones
the ones with a lot of energy are
leaving then the ones that are left over
on average going to have a lower kinetic
energy or a lower temperature and so
that is what is cooling you down at a
molecular level
let's first think